hey sir hey man i'm a favorite man
come this way
put your hand behind your back you're
changing my back got it you got it
you got it you got it
is there any reason you are doing this
bro
what's going on my man trying to put
money on my arm
he said what
is your phone
[Applause]
philippine woman i was in the backseat
did y'all have her design right now yes
she's being detented all right uh can
you uh do the officers explain what's
going on while we're out here not really
man all right so we got a call back i
heard that i heard somebody ask me if i
passed it no yeah this might have been
one of these that was lit so basically
we got a call and uh from what we got
the call it seems like someone was
trying to rob the bank uh something
about you passing a note to the teller
something to that effect
uh can you just tell me what's going on
yeah bro
it's a it's a medical assistant that
works in my house that prefers to be
paid in cash
every time i make a withdrawal to pay
her
you know because it's a large amount she
works a lot yeah
you know if i if i don't if i don't
write down on a note
how much i went out
and then i don't want to run through the
money counter right there at the desk
the whole bank ends up looking at me
because hear the money going through the
money
and i don't feel safe i don't feel safe
getting money out like that so every
time i go to withdraw it
you know i put that i put the amount
yeah i'm going to take another
and i put my own card in
and then i and then i usually take me
out like oh it's just just get the get
the money you know what i'm saying
i don't
understand
you make well that's like i said that's
the reason why we're out here and that's
the reason why we detained everybody
because we didn't know exactly what was
going on
so you may try i mean i gotta be honest
with you
yeah well unfortunately in those
situations
where's your id in this pocket
do you need to get some fresh air you
need to take the mask off for a second
to get some fresh air
okay i got five months old baby i'm
wrong i'm gonna take my mask yeah
so i'm just trying there's my
so
like i was i was about to tell you um
the reason we don't uh come out and and
unfortunately the the seriousness of the
call doesn't allow us to obviously let
me ask you a question
you're talking to me right now
and i'm cuffed in the back of the car
yeah my teams and drivers cut yeah i
imagine in the back of the car
and and my baby nurse that takes care of
my baby's cuff in the back of the car
yeah is there any reason we can have
this conversation once you get these
coaches off everybody yeah and we'd like
to be in trailer like yeah that's kind
of very exciting
yeah that's fine we'll go ahead and uh
get you out of the handcuffs i thought i
had this conversation with you man hey
guys i wasn't
getting you guys out of handcuffs hold
i i i i i stated to the officers that
arrest me
that had that had that glocks out yeah
i was pulling money on my own account i
understand i put the i put my own bank
card in there
before the light you went in the back
you know what i'm saying
so
we have to confirm that you gotta
understand we can't we don't come out
because of the seriousness of the call
we don't just come out and unfortunately
in a situation like that you don't get
the benefit of the doubt we detain and
then we ask questions later
um
that's what exactly what i went inside
for you you can take them out the other
people want a handcuff
so that's why we come out with weapons
that's why you're detained and then we
ask questions later because of the
nature
so um
see it again sir
um
it's not there's nothing for me to say
man like i gotta get all y'all name yeah
that's fine yeah
my own account but
you know you know what i mean like like
i
i gotta i gotta
i don't know if she ever had been
arrested before you know i'm saying i
don't know my team's never been arrested
before you know what i'm saying like i
guess
i was trying to communicate that with
them you know what i mean yeah i got i
got everything for my badge i got my id
hanging on my head i got you that's what
i'm saying
do you understand where we're coming
from do you understand that we're not we
didn't just show up here
and put draw guns on him
we showed up because the call was
uh came in i i i understand yeah
that's all i know
right now you know
you